o lapso só hoje por fax a mágica do
último de vela são duas e pronto é mais
que consiste em chamar o animal jacarta
concelho e começaram a brincar com as
cartas toda a gente fazia isso é
responsável cujo até aos 60 e tal
se você seguiu se a todas as cartas
ficam iguais às pessoas para a área
victor a gente fazer
a icann df ainda não tinha ver como é
que fazes total do baralho é especial
não afronta a não ir lá fazer com que
mais um truque
aprendi que os truques que acha que com
o mestre parar ea pessoa vai cortar
várias vezes mas agora a coisa é o
momento ideal de instabilidade só não
consegue mandar bocas tão bom aprender
magia como na escola e tal e pronto
então você esconda uma carta três pontos
sempre aparece várias vezes essa casa
você tem que esconder um sítio qualquer
um pode pôr na caixa das cartas e vocês
estão ali pela caixa traz tê-las ontem
uma carta nesse momento só aí virados
para trás e olhar para a caixa geral do
prêmio olha a inapa ainda assim é o 3
então nesse momento você não vai trocar
o baralho especial porque já vi como é
feito por um baralho que só vai faltar a
esta casa então você foi embora na mesa
suponha cartas no baralho e começa a
jogar um jogo normal e pronto o salto
vai destinar cerca do assunto e poderá
sempre dizer mal das 109 min
agora não vi vocês querem saber não é
normal
o baralho em 24 é o trecho são
ligeiramente mais pequenas e mais o que
dar uma carta à sua escolha
315 branco com aquela máquina dos
fotógrafos
vai ficar um corpo espetacular 31 bater
sempre as cartas em que uma carta de
baixo vai ser símbolo treschow capa você
escolher o jogo de cartas no sítio volta
a fazer a mesma coisa e mostra uma cara
assim estima vão ser sempre katz normal
de consciência
e pronto mostra casa diz que não é e
pronto vocês quando uma carta
esses foram três casos 13 e pronto faz
aquele momento de diversão sendo assim e
prontas houve põe no baralho em
continuar o jogo ninguém vai perceber na
e pronto só eu espero realmente gostar e
até o próximo vídeo mágico nam e não há
magia